what is going on there reject nation greg here
today thank you so much for clicking on this video
so this is the second movie that i easily get
the most crap for never having seen i'm a 90s kid
never saw this film never i tell people i've
never seen it it's again the same thing i have
with forrest gump was i can't believe you have not
seen the shawshank redemption it's so good yeah
figured why not do a movie reaction i'm actually
shooting this like midnight right now on whatever
random day this i don't remember what day today is
my schedule's been off ever since stranger things
but we are here and i'm excited to watch it thank
you so much for clicking if you can leave a like
that would be so appreciated also subscribe and
click that notification bell and as per usual full
length reaction watch alongs where you sync up
with your own copy i'm watching this off hbo max
is over at our patreon page for super sexy
rejects cover a whole bunch of shows over
there as well we're at the same tier you get the
option for reaction highlights and watch long's
included any movie or show that we cover here
the full-length watch along is available over
at our patreon page thank you to the prepper
team for helping me edit down these highlights
i know it takes place in a prison that's about
all i know let's see what's going on in this film
what happened after you argued with your wife
she packed a bag to go and stay with mr quinton
glenn quentin the golf pro at the snowden hills
country club the man you had recently discovered
was your wife's lover david prova from the
sopranos is in this drove to his house to
confront them they weren't home so i parked in the
turnout and waited with one intention i'm not sure
i was confused uh drunk well i hope you murdered
her well where i get hazy is where the cleaning
woman shows up the following morning and finds
your wife in bed with her lover riddled with
38-caliber bullets how does that strike you as a
fantastic coincidence mr defrayner is it just me
you're coming across a little guilty dude
yet you still maintain that you threw your
gun into the river before the murders took
place it's the truth since i am innocent
of this crime sir i find it decidedly
inconvenient that the gun was never found
that's a very good response we have the accused
at the scene of the crime we have footprints
tire tracks we have bullets screwing on the
ground which bear his fingerprints a broken
bourbon bottle likewise with fingerprints and
most of all roger deacon's cinematography by the
power vested in me by the state of maine i hereby
order you to serve two life sentences back to back
it's weird tim robbins and morgan freeman look dh
to me so you see how they look now we see by your
file you have served 20 years of a life sentence
yes sir you feel you've been rehabilitated
oh yes sir no longer danger to
society that's god's honest truth
oh i don't know why i'm already
rooting for him let's get out of here
wow this looks like one hell of a prison
i would love to visit this location
if it's not still an active person
new blood
holy [__] is that clancy brown
everyone's so de-aged in this movie looked
like a stiff breeze would blow him over
that was my first impression of the man what do
you say a tall drink of water with a silver spoon
up his ass never had 10 cigarettes that's
a rich bet this looks like a fun prison
it's interesting how it can successfully
shift perspective between morgan freeman's
character and tim robbins so effortlessly
effortlessly i'm mr norden the warden
you are convicted felons that's
why they've sent you to me
rule number one no blasphemy god damn it the
first night's the toughest no doubt about it
somebody always breaks down grind it's
as good a thing to bet on as any i guess
i had my money on andy dufresne god prison must
really suck i don't belong here we have a winner
and it's fat ass by a nose fist fist fish
good old william sadler man you don't
understand i'm not supposed to be here open that
oh my god if i hear so much as a mouse fart in
here the rest of the night i swear by god and
sonny jesus you will all visit the infirmary every
last [__] in here i hope a mouse doesn't fart
goddamn i never want to meet clancy brown but god
damn do i respect him his first night in the joint
and dufresne cost me two packs of cigarettes he
never made a sound that's a damn good white boy
there's so much character to this prison
like just the environment and the structure
oh my god are you going to eat that
i hadn't planned on it do you mind
uh that's nice and ripe what the [__]
oh okay all right jake says thank you i hope that
bird doesn't die fine morning in it you know why
it's a fine morning don't you come on set them
down i want them all lined up here just like a
pretty little chorus line damn red looks pissed
i was just wondering if anyone knew his name
doesn't [__] matter what his name was he's dead
i tell you you feel a little bad
about it don't you wife killing banker
why'd you do it i didn't since
you asked you gonna fit right in
or maybe you'd like to sink your toe into
somebody's skull no sir i have no enemies here no
wait a while yep sisters have taken quite a liking
to you especially boggs i don't suppose it would
help any if i explain to them i'm not homosexual
it would not well if there's any trouble i won't
use the rock hammer they find it you're gonna lose
it they do catch you with it you don't know me
i understand i could see why some
of the boys took him for snobby
they had a quiet way about him there's
such a good cat mystery between them
i think it would be fair to
say i liked andy from the start
red
red's the kind of guy you could be friends
with outside of prison too right running low
ah [__]
yep there it is
i wish i could tell you that andy fought the
good fight but prison is no fairytale world he
never said who did it but we all knew yeah that's
horrible i do believe those first two years were
the worst for two years it was outdoor detail and
may is one damn fine month to be working outdoors
ellis reading wouldn't you know it me and some
fellas i know were among the names called 35 000
that's what he left me poor barons
terrible [__] luck huh crying shame
some people really got it awful step aside mert
this fucker's having himself an accident you don't
push him off the roof because if you do trust
it there's no reason you can't keep that 35 000.
35 000. all of it all of it every
penny you better start making sense
give it to your wife the irs allows
a one-time only gift to your spouse
for up to sixty thousand dollars oh [__]
tax-free tax-free irs can't touch one cent
yeah that smart banker would kill his wife aren't
you why should i believe a smart banker like you
cause he's a smart banker if you get the forms
i'll prepare them for you nearly free of charge
i'd only ask three beers a piece for each of
my co-workers i think a man working outdoors
feels more like a man if you can have a bottle
of suds okay and that's how it came to pass
not bad as for andy he spent that break
hungered in the shade a strange little
smile on his face watching us drink his beer
want a cold one andy no thanks gave up drinking
you're a nice guy what do you want rita
hayworth what so this is johnny farrell
i've heard a lot about you johnny really take
a few weeks weeks well yeah andy i don't have a
stuff down in front of my pants right now i'm
sorry to say how would you get rita hayward
and to spend a month in the infirmary
the sisters never laid a finger on
andy again and boggs never walked again
well okay i'm thinking andy could use a nice
welcome back when he gets out of the infirmary
man likes to place chess let's get him some rocks
i love this reaction
oh heads up toss and sells
oh no
a real messed up way of inspecting
[__] pleased to see you reading this
any favorite passages watch ye therefore for
you know not when the master of the house coming
hey jake where's brooks tandy and i i thought
i heard you out here i've been reassigned to
you i know they told me ain't that a kick
in the head ain't that a kick in the head
i'm deacons i was uh
thinking about maybe setting up some kind
of trust fund for my kids educations ah
mr deakins and then andy says it mr deacon you
want your sons to go to harvard or yay bars are
concerned only three ways to spend the taxpayers
hard-earned when it comes to prisons more walls
more bars more guards still i i'd like to try
with your permission i'll write a letter a week
they can't ignore me forever sure can i'll even
mail them for you how's that will you mail them
the following april andy did tax
returns for half the guards of shawshank
oh my god year after that he did
them all including the wardens
year after that they rescheduled the start of
the intramural season to coincide with taxis
oh my goodness yes sir and it was a regular
cottage industry in fact it got so busy at tax
time he was allowed to staff oh cool so put the
knife down brooks brooks look at me put the knife
down hmm brooks huh look at his neck for god's
sake it's the only way they'd let me stay come
on this is crazy what what the hell did you do to
send him off anyway i didn't do nothing i come in
here to say fairly well ain't you heard his parole
come through i just don't understand what happened
in there that's fine oh man this is his home
you can never get like that oh yeah say that
when you've been here as long as brookson's
goddamn right they send you here for life
that's exactly what they take part it
counts anyway that is crazy i wonder how
if that happens often to people i can't
take care of you no more jake you go on now
you're free oh
wow
god 50 years man i can't believe
how fast things move on the outside
i saw an automobile once when i was a kid but
i was just thinking about that just thinking
about that the parole board got me into this
halfway house called the brewer and a job
it's hard work i try to keep up but my hands
hurt most of the time oh sometimes after work
i go to the park and feed the birds i keep
thinking jake might just show up and say hello
but he never does oh poor guy i
have bad dreams like i'm falling
i wake up scared sometimes it takes
me a while to remember where i am
it's so fascinating maybe i should get me a
gun and rob the food way so they'd send me home
i've decided not to stay i doubt they'll
kick up any fuss not for an old crook like me
oh holy [__]
yes tell hey what i'm sorry i put a
knife to his throat a hard feeling damn
that was such an unexpected
part of this movie to me
what's all this you tell me [__]
stick they're all addressed to you
huh what this is 200 in addition the
library district has generously responded
with a charitable donation
of used books and sundries
we trust this will fill your needs we now consider
the matter closed please stop sending us a letter
it only took six years from now on i'll
write two letters a week instead of one
andy do you hear that
is that italian music
don't be too bold man okay you're going bold
you will now be competing in this year's
hunger games it was like some beautiful
bird flapped into our trap little cage and
made those walls dissolve away and for the
briefest of moments every last man at shawshank
felt free that's why he did it for that feeling
i am warning you dufresne turn that off
oh great and it got two weeks in the hole for that
little stunt on your feet and you you couldn't
play something good huh and hank williams they
broke the door down before i could take requests
that's the beauty of music
they can't get that from you
haven't you ever felt that way about music i
play the main monica as a younger man yeah lost
interest in it though didn't make much sense
in here here's where it makes the most sense
you need it so you don't forget come on ready
get a harmonica hope it's a dangerous thing
hope to drive a man insane he's got no use on
the inside oh i better get used to that idea
i hope you get out of here by the end red
you feel you've been rehabilitated oh yes
and i can honestly say i'm a changed man no
danger to society here god's honest truth
and the hope debate lives on here
little parole rejection present
go ahead and open it
i had to go through one of your competitors i
hope you don't mind i wanted to be a surprise
he got the harmonica
thank you you're gonna play it
oh
not right now when you get out
guys such a long time
i know rita hayworth who the hell is that and
you'd be amazed how far andy could stretch it
he made deals with book clubs charity groups
he bought remainder books by the pound count
monte crisco that's christo you dumb [__]
the rest of us did our best to
pitch in when and where we could
by the year kennedy was shot and they
had transformed the storage room smelling
of rat turds and turpentine into the
best prison library in new england wow
address this thank you sir have this shitty pie
problem with having all that money the sonar lady
you're gonna have to explain where it came from
well that's where i come in i send that money
out into the real world and when it comes back
cleaners of virgins honey potter the time norton
retires i'll have made him a millionaire now
you're a real criminal i know you're good at it
but all that paper leaves a trail fbi irs whatever
it's gonna lead to somebody i'm sure it is
but not to me certainly not to the warden randall
stephen who second cousin to harvey the rabbit he
doesn't exist except on paper you can't just make
a person up mr stevens has a birth certificate
driver's license social security number you're
[__] me i had to come to prison to be a crook
i got the tv like this it's a big old thing i
couldn't see [__] freeze kid hands in the air
you hear what i said boy i say yes sir i sure did
but if i dropped this [__] thing you got me on
destruction of property too you don't seem to be
a very good thief maybe you should try something
else yeah well what the hell you know about it
capone what are you in for me lawyer [__] me
everybody's innocent in here don't you know that
tim province is so good in this feel
bad let him down oh that's crap kid
he's proud of you what's he in here
for anyway murder the hell you say
caught his wife in bed with
some golf bro we used them both
four years ago i was in thomas and on a two to
three stretch oh my god no way about six months
left to go get a new cell mate in elmo blatch
big twitchy [__] oh my god he knows who did it
so i pick out this guy gives me [__] so he
killed him him in this tasty [__] he was with
she's [__] this prixy this golf pro but
she's very some other guy oh my god some
hot shot banker oh my god and he's the one they
painted on jesus that's everything right there
i have to say that's the most amazing story i
ever heard sir oh they would want to keep him here
the country club will have his old time cards
records w-2s with his name on it frane if you
want to indulge this fantasy that's your business
don't make it mine this meeting is over oh
get in here now she's trying to set your mind at
ease that's all sir cemetery a month oh my god
the kid passed c plus average oh wow
just made the cut jordan wants to talk
no no this does not look like good news i have
to know if what you told dufresne was the truth
yes sir absolutely would you be willing to swear
before a judge and jury having placed your hand on
the good book just give me that chance why does
this feel like a mislead that's what i thought
god damn it i'm sure by now you've heard a
terrible thing less than a year ago trying
to escape broke kept natalie's heart to shoot him
we just have to put it behind us oh my god i hope
you get [__] the electric chair man you will
do the hardest time there is no more protection
from the guards catching my drift or am i being
obtuse give him another month to think about it
another month i didn't pull the trigger
i drove her away and that's why she died because
of me oh no feel bad about it if you want to but
you didn't pull the trigger no i didn't i
think he'll ever get out of here one day
when i got a long white beard and two or three
marbles rolling around upstairs they let me out
he'll become god i guess it comes
down to a simple choice really
you're busy living you'll get busy die
god the acting in this is so good
he asked me for a lengthy rope bro
six feet long and you gave it
to me sure i did why wouldn't i
remember brooks hamlin no
and he'd never do that every man has his
breaking point look at me split want to get home
come on figure it out my stuff down the laundry
and shine my shoes i want them looking
like mirrors good having you back andy
place wasn't the same without you it's
completely stripping of everything
he gets his most hopeful opportunity
and then that's when all hope becomes lost man
missing on tier two cell 245. do fray get your
ass out here boy you hold up the show don't make
me come down there i'll thump your skull for you
maybe he broke out
tell me what this is last night's
account mm-hmm i sure do see right there
dufresne i want him found not tomorrow not
after breakfast now how to get out did he use
that shovel thingy this is a conspiracy
damn conspiracy and everyone's in on it
no no
in 1966 andy dufresne escaped from shawshank
prison please tell me he got all they found of
him was a muddy set of prison clothes a bar
of soap and an old rock hammer there it is
that's when he had the idea turns out and his
favorite hobby was toting his wall out into
the exercise yard a handful at a time and he
decided he'd been here just about long enough
look at this good i want to get home oh please
tell me there's [__] in there to convict him
three deposits tonight
yes he took it andy crawl to freedom
through 500 yards of [__] smelling
foulness i can't even imagine
or maybe i just don't want to
some goddamn determination that's the
length of five football fields oh my god
you clever son of a [__]
please tell me he gets away
please a man nobody ever laid eyes on
before strolled into the main national bank
until that moment he didn't exist
except on paper did he know my god
driver's license price certificate social
security card and the signature was a spot on yeah
i hope you'll enjoy living abroad it's so good
i love this will there be anything else
please could you add this to your outgoing mail
i'd be happy to oh good this is so cathartic
all told he blew town with better than
370 000 of warden norton's money wow
good morning portland daily bubble
oh man
this is the greatest finale in all of movie
history right here i wasn't there to see
it but i hear byron hadley started sobbing
like a little girl when they took him away
a little [__] norton had no
intention of going that quietly
oh no make it easy on yourself
man nah he deserved to rot in prison i got
a postcard in the mail when i picture him
heading south in his own car with a top down it
always makes me laugh i have to remind myself
that some birds aren't meant to be caged does
red get out no i guess i just miss my friend
please for the love of christ let her go
if i'll say you've served 40 years of a life
sentence feel you've been rehabilitated it's
just a [__] word so you go on and stamp
your form sonny and stop wasting my time
oh yeah he did it did he get
to say goodbye to his friends
yeah they just put them up in the same ass place
oh man find that oak tree if andy already
didn't go to it there's a harsh truth to face
no way i'm gonna make it on the outside
don't say that man please for the love of
god toad all i do anymore is think of ways
to break my parole only one thing stops me
a promise i made to andy like a tree
that god would send messages through
that rock that rock definitely doesn't
look like it belongs to the other rocks
he went back there and left
a letter for him didn't he
he did if you're reading this you've gotten out
and if you've come this far maybe you're
willing to come a little further you remember
the name of the town don't you say about the
name yeah it's good every day remember red
hope is a good thing maybe the best of things that
is so beautiful i'm guilty of committing a crime
a role violation of course i doubt they'll toss up
any roadblocks for that board and got texas please
i'm so happy right now
oh yes
wow oh that was so beautiful
that was very touching
that was extremely touching i wish we got to see
him say bye to his friends in prison though red
release the extended is there a post-credits
scene of red's friends sitting around just going
anyone's seen red lately haven't seen red around
here oh beautiful that was beautiful okay wow
what a journey what a journey
where to begin it's really an
ultimate bromance movie isn't it
do people say that about this film
do people say this is a bromance
i really didn't know anything about it uh i i i
knew it took place in a prison that's all i've
ever really known about it and of course seeing
the poster for it i didn't realize that's what
the poster was gonna be representing ultimately
in the end and uh i was very satisfied with it
you know like from just the the takeaway of
like the main technical things that i imagine
people always mean not all this technical
uh however you know you thinking about like
the performances are just phenomenal like morgan
freeman is excellent just so natural and it's
interesting because you usually see nowadays you
see him kind of play like i mean he does a lot of
he does a lot of types of work now but you don't
really get to see him do rules like this anymore
i mean maybe he does and i'm just out of the loop
but in terms of like the prominent films or the
bigger films he tends to be a part of the rules
like this not so much and so to get it to see him
do this role is so real so natural and and same
thing with tim robbins just excellent in this film
uh very internal performance subdued and i i think
the way they often times when you do stories that
span a lot of time like they spend a lot of time
here and oftentimes you do stories like this
it can feel you can feel like it's it's
going a little too like imagine like a
typical biopic where you complain about you
know the way they span time just imagine those
complaints applied to here and i would not
apply that here yet i think that's part of
the uniqueness of it is you can feel kind
of the wear and tear it does on the soul
of these characters but it's never done in a
way that feels forceful it all feels so natural
because you know you start this movie out with you
know red getting rejected once again to get out of
shawshank and he doesn't seem as resistant towards
the possibility of him getting out and then as the
movie progresses you know any time the talk of
dreams or escaping or being let go from here
that it you could see that there's such pushback
there's such a defense mechanism that comes up
in the conversation and that the thought of that
is a threat the thought of that is a fear to to
it's like painful to think about because it will
never come true that's or or if it does come true
terror awaits because now it's been so conditioned
and this is home now this is most of most of the
individual life is spent here that the outside
world is uncomfortable and you don't belong
you know like a lot of these people who who
wind up here end up finding a different place
of belonging in a different place of purpose
so i like like the details and i think that's
one of the things about this movie is it's the
details it's really easy to look at a film like
this i imagine especially after with 94.
god so many movies damn good movies came
out there um i don't know if this film won
any awards i i actually i'm way out of the
loop on this i believe it lost the forest gump
that's what i believe is that the right anywho
it's easy to look at a film like this and go
uh yeah melodramatic a little bit predictable
i mean predictable in terms of where the
plots might end up but it's about the details
of the experience it's about getting lost in it
because i actually thought this movie was more
immersive than i was expecting it to be like i
don't often depends on you know exactly what kind
of film you're watching and i wasn't expecting
to get as swept up in it or as immersed in it
and weirdly i actually think a lot of that credit
goes to morgan freeman's narration a classic
morgan freeman narration is this when it started
the classic morgan freeman narration because
you know often out in l.a you meet a
lot of people who are screenwriters and
you hear uh you know people constantly debate
like narration is a weak man's storytelling
motif like don't do it and i actually thought
it was used quite effectively and i thought it
actually helped enhance the immersiveness
of the film because you are weaving in and
out of two perspectives throughout this film
you're weaving it out of red's perspective and
you're weaving into andy's perspective and
there's the juxtaposition there's the clash
of andy who is trying obviously as stated in
the film is trying to hold on to hope maintain
some level of optimism and then you have red who
as time goes on is losing more and more of that
hope and the fear is becoming the by the way just
gotta say this really fast the brooks character
very effective stuff i love that they allowed the
film to break away from the main two narratives of
red and andy and just spend time like a
little short film within this massive film
to spend time with brooks on the outside
world and really show that feeling of being
living in this isolated place and you know
going from a place where you you found family
you found friends you you found order you know
in some weird way and you found purpose like he
all of us i imagine imagine all of us long for
a sense of belonging and a sense of feeling
like we have some type of purpose um whether
that be on a major level or a minor level
you know and anything that helps us feel like
we belong and usually that's associated with
like what's my purpose in here and it's so easy
to define that where it's kind of like you're
starting all over again it's easy to get kind of
lost in the masses and also you know you're when
you're there for so long you're out of touch
with the way times have changed you haven't
changed with the times because you weren't
around to experience the societal changes
and they really captured that so so eloquently
perfect with the brooks character that it was
heartbreaking like that to me was uh one of the
most heartbreaking parts of this whole story
was seeing how that happens that's the
fear that every man eventually has when
i like that really opened my eyes to you
know like there's there's constantly a lot of
talks um you know circular that i'm not as well
versed in as i ought to be or i haven't taken the
time to dive into incarceration treatment and
just how messed up it is you know because like
i only ever truly hear about like the terrible
people when i watch like true crime documentaries
or something like that or a true crime docu
series and like yeah lock them away for good
but the the mistreatment of people who are like
nah they shouldn't be incarcerated for that long
you know and that's movie kind of shows that
and it also shows the kind of negative effect
it can have because you imagine that you're in
prison oh my god you've been there for so long
you must just want to get out but then i never
thought about that feeling it's like it's not
exactly stockholm syndrome but i imagine
in some ways it can kind of feel it's just
it's habitual it's like this
is your habitat now you know
and and and i think the way they painted that
with the brook storyline was really powerful
and so then you have here the juxtaposition
between the two main characters you know which
path is it gonna go down for them which belief
system will ultimately fall under because the
story's so much about resilience and perseverance
in the face of obstacles where everything just
seems like andy was sexually assaulted physically
beaten tortured abused on all the counts stripped
of everything and he never gave up and he was
always and i think there's there is a certain
level what i thought was cool about the way it's
about this how it's woven is this sort of woven
like i would use the words woven like a
tail because um t-a-l-e for clarity on that
because red is so much about think realistic
and andy's journey is a bit of this cathartic
fantasy fulfillment of the man wronged
who managed to inspire and influence
these people and and and have them be educated
and do good deeds and look and grow bigger hearts
grow some love and expand their love expand their
vocabulary and then manage to use his imagination
to break out of there put the warden behind and
get the warden caught on his corruption like
so he's living he's he's bringing the fantasy
to life you know because i imagine that for
this character he is fantasizing about the
outcome that he ultimately does get not just
being able to be in mexico and be on the beach
and it's it's all the other things that happen
along the way the details and bringing that to
reality and i think stories like this are so
timeless because even if you're not i've
never been incarcerated or been close to
and most of us haven't and i i feel like
though that there's so much here that is
relatable in our own ways you know because i
this character with an home kind of hopping all
over the place here it's a it's a long movie
and it's three in the morning right now um
like with the andy character because he is
so downtrodden and it's not a story of like
i was wrong i need to get out of here it's he
accepts his prison sentence pretty early on
as a like this punishment as if he is deserving of
it and as the movie reveals that he he ultimately
did feel like even though he's not the one who
pulled the trigger that he did feel responsible
for his wife's death and that guilt is the thing
that has allowed him to accept this condemnation
and try to make the most of it and then
try to do some good while he's in there too
i forgot where i was going with the point but
i was just getting kind of lost in that because
oh yes that is a very relatable point that's
a very relatable thing in its own way of
you know a lot of us often can fall into the
feelings of guilt or shame in ways that are not
actually our faults but we accept them
as our faults and punish ourselves
and you do got to get to a point of climbing
out of that hole you literally there's like
it's such a good metaphor of like climbing
out of this hole now the time has come
to feel be free of it all again like he's accepted
his sentence he hasn't even fought to get out he's
he didn't put up a fight this whole time he
was there he just accepted it and now he gets
to climb out of that hole and i think the other
main relatable part of it of what i imagine has
made this movie just develop in popularity over
time and has been so timeless is the fact that
that that thought process of thinking
realistic i know he's not the most
popular person to quote right now but will smith
would often talk about this is think like not
the feelings of thinking realistic
and the feelings of being a dreamer
you know being someone who can hold on to a
fantasy and try to make that fantasy become the
reality because when you think realistic that's
so limiting and you just pigeonhole yourself into
having not such a fulfilling life and i i
think you know painting a story like that's
the basis of the the narrative and the themes
of don't get caught up and thinking realistic
learn to be hopeful learn to be be a dreamer think
bigger you know it's but it's in the story of
prison sentence and and then ultimately in the
finale of a prison of a breaking out of prison
so i think having rooted in those themes of
despite all things that are piling on against you
despite all odds all the obstacles you don't don't
forget to hold on to that hope that's why that
scene with the music is so beautiful uh
where he plays the replays that with that
inspiration that feeling of escapism and that
escapism doesn't have to be just a form of
you know stepping away from reality like yes
but there's a beauty to that that's why we like
watching [__] movies man that's why we like
watching shows it is an escapism it totally is
but if you can run away with some sense
of inspiration that you can actually apply
then beautiful things can come from that you know
and you know when you hear people that say movies
change my life i always kind of wonder like to
what degree has it changed your life is it just
the feeling that it gave you or did you actually
like do something with that feeling or the thought
process that sparked and yeah then something
really did change for you and i can imagine that
this movie can have that effect for people that
either grew up with it or found it pretty early
on in life or maybe they found it late in life
and then they they were able to uh hold on to
any of that inspiration that stayed in their brain
and their heart and then rolled with it so there's
so much beauty here and i i don't know i guess i
was expecting to walk into like a dark-ass drama
because i heard prison movie and it's r-rated
and yeah i mean it definitely feels r-rated and
i heard you know stephen king wrote it so i do i
wasn't expecting a movie that leaned more into the
those optimistic qualities and i appreciated
that so much and i think frank darabont did it
did an excellent job because so much about this
movie to beyond just capturing the span of time
working with his editor oh the music by thomas
oh phenomenal too that is that's great music
like you know it's like i'm so used to
roger deacon's cinematography as of now
which is [__] like prisoners and blade
runners like striking dark moody ass [__]
i forgot this was roger deakins but i think they
captured the the personality of the prisons so
well beyond just its cast of characters the
architecture of it all there there was a there
is a sense of of history and who these people
evolved into and and i like that it didn't just
hone in on things that i would normally expect
which is people just kind of going crazy
like it's going stir crazy it leaned more
into uh finding light and darkness which was
something i wasn't expecting it's in some ways
if you just cut out a few things or change some
dialogue and and switch around some scenes it
could have been a pg-13 movie but it wouldn't
have been as good of a movie it wouldn't have
been as effective you need some of the harsher
[__] in here in order for a lot of these other
things to hit home much stronger in the fields
so yeah i mean i thought it was a beautiful
film i thought it was really strong
and i'm glad i've watched it it's such a random
move for me to watch i've been watching so many
things um in my you know some things on camera
here a lot of more emotional [__] there's so
much more like things where i'm like damn i've
been watching a lot of emotional stuff lately
uh but even off camera you know i've been watching
like a lot more things that are about like
love and doing doing kinder things doing
good things and uh being more optimistic
in life about a lot of what i watch and i'm also
catching up on westworld i'm only on season two
so there's there's that which is
not the feelings i'm talking about
but then you know i'm also watching like love on
the spectrum a great netflix reality show which i
i highly recommend and um yeah yeah uh this this
movie was impactful in a way i wasn't expecting
you know i met i i thought it would just be this
downtrodden dark depressing hole of the film and
then eventually it would become this very touching
moving inspirational drama but it was kind of
kind of the vibe throughout and i and and i
wasn't expecting that and uh and i'm glad it'd
be filled with that it was it was awesome tim
robbins is excellent morgan freeman's good the
wrestling william sadler is a wonderful presence
the warden [__] i forget that actor's name but
he's very effective here uh clancy brown always
an effective [__] it's funny how clancy brown
forgot how creepy crap clancy brown looked when
he was younger because clancy brown today you know
i've uh what is like a modern touchdown is it the
main betty and uh i don't know if you guys watched
it but the revival of the the real final season
of dexter and that's that's the clancy brown
that comes to mind for me now just like a heavier
set guy with white hair and a beard like that's
that's classic brown i know or someone who's like
a lot of makeup or does a lot of voice over work
he's got his voice has become more definitive
over time and i forgot how creepy this guy was
he's a little creepy looking he seems nicer now
like when he plays like a nicer party i actually
believe him but damn i forgot how creepy he was
but the but the costume design on this film was
also excellent too everything about this i
i love the art direction of it very much so
so yeah fascinating to learn more facts about
it but really touching stuff and a great great
messages and i i love the ending of it as well
yeah i i wasn't expecting it to be like damn
this finale is cool this is a cool finale and that
wasn't the vibe but i think it earned it so much
and i love how they like planted all the seeds
for every little every little bit of that escape
plan and i like how it just it it went through
like he escaped and he did it it wasn't you know
being chased by dogs in the middle of the night
streets and i get over there to get them you know
like crazy elaborate plan walked off with a
lot of money use the phantom to be able to
to get some documents out there got the the warden
caught i thought it was great it was excellent
excellent films oh yeah shout out to my friend
andrew gordon i have any friend in real life
who has been insistent on me watching this i think
he declares this as his favorite movie out of any
friend who's been insistent on me watching it it's
been andrew gordon and many of you guys suggested
it after forrest gump and uh i'm glad i did
this was uh this was a nice experience so thank
you guys very much subscribe leave a like and
we'll catch you all catch you all soon thank you
you